so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about Marvel's first black
superhero the blue marvel Adam Brashear
however before we get into this video I
want to let people know ahead of time
that some of the phrases used in this
story to describe african-americans and
other non-white cultures may be
considered a little offensive and while
the intention is not to be malicious I'm
keeping these phrases in this video as I
serve to establish the significance of
both the story itself as well as the
perception the world had a blue Marvel
and the way he viewed himself
so Adam Brashear was created by Kevin
Griffo who was also the mastermind
behind both the underworld and I
frankenstein series as well as a writer
for Superman Batman and others in an
interview with the source a digital
imprint media hub for news relating to
urban music african-american issues
youth culture and politics
Corvo had stated that the character of
Adam Brashear was as much a reflection
of himself as he was a wholly new
character for Marvel Comics what I mean
here is that as a graduate of Howard
University Kevin Griffo sport folio
consists of a stint as a football player
as well as a bachelor's degree in
microbiology with minors in chemistry
and psychology in addition to a master's
in genetic engineering furthermore as an
african-american born in 1962 and
growing up during the early days of the
civil rights movement and his youth
Kevin Grebo experienced racism from
various directions and as such folded
these concepts over into his writing of
the blue Marvel character in addition to
this during the same interview the
question was asked about his view of
diversity and comics regarding
superheroes of color created by writers
of color and his answer guru had stated
that to him while there were multiple
black artists there were very few
writers who are black while he
acknowledged this isn't necessarily
indicative of a systemic issue of racism
the problem arises when writers create
content based on their own personal
experiences as a result the most
prominent black superheroes and Marvel
Comics in particular are Sam Wilson
Black Panther and storm only one of whom
could be considered a wildly powerful
being and in effort to rectify this
Grebo had sought to create a black
superhero that as he put it could sit at
the table of Superman Martian Manhunter
Shazam and the century and hold his own
as a character that could rise to almost
any occasion and save the world but also
had a level of intelligence that could
rival Marvel's smartest beings including
Reed Richards Tony Stark and Amadeus Cho
as a result in November of 2008 he
released a semi period five-part
miniseries titled The Legend of blue
Marvel which took a page from paul jing
is in jail 'yes this century and
introduced adam Beshear as a superhero
who existed prior to the dawn of
characters like Black Panther spider-man
and the x-men but left the scene due to
the culture of racism in the United
States during the early 1960s having
said that the legend of blue Marvel
bounces back and forth between the 1960s
and the events immediately following
civil war
and the death of Captain America in that
during this time Tony Stark is director
of shield Carol Danvers leaves the
Avengers branch off team called the
Mighty Avengers and the roster of the
main Avengers team itself consists of
the century Robert Reynolds Tony Stark
Ares the Greek god of war Black Widow
Yellow Jacket Hank Pym and she-hulk and
the opening events of this story the
group is in the midst of a battle with a
being named ante man someone who will be
explored further in the story but the
significance of this battle is that it
serves to set the stage for the coming
events by establishing a kind of blue
Marvel is the only one who can save us
idea and that the Avengers are being
completely ravaged by an time and the
century for example is it being on par
with the Hulk even in his angriest form
but against an T man he poses no true
threat and is easily taken down in
addition to this Ares is an Olympian and
the son of Zeus and Hera with prodigious
skill in battle while his strength is
less than both Thor and the century key
along with she-hulk Carol Danvers and
everyone else is virtually useless here
and so with Ironman demanding to know
why the anti man is here both his
motives and the first mission of blue
Marvel come when he responds that his
purpose is to bring salvation to the
planet Earth and that not even blue
Marvel was able to stop him when the two
had previously fought and so as a battle
comes to a close the indication here is
that an T man was on a timetable with a
limit to how long he could exist or at
the very least fight under these
conditions which becomes apparent when
he effectively dissolves and fades away
now recovering from the battle Griffo
continues to tease us with the power of
blue Marvel when the Sentry comments on
how powerful an T man was and that he
has never experienced a being on such a
scale
furthermore Tony Stark pulls the group
together arguing that because such a
being exists the only way for them to
defeat him is to understand who he is
and where his power comes from now from
here we jump back to 1962 with our first
depiction of blue Marvel himself in a
battle with the anti man now the
reasoning behind the anti man's actions
largely remain ambiguous here and that
the statements between the two of them
as they do battle indicate that an T man
intends a larger into the world kind of
scenario with blue Marvel doing what he
can to stop him
furthermore as he's depicted here blue
Marvel has all the hallmarks of a
traditional hero and that he refuses to
give up in the midst of the battle he
does what he can to keep innocence
protected and he also attempts to talk
anti man down from his rampage however
as a true villain an T man is the
antithesis of blue Marvel and that he's
unwavering from his goal of presumed
genocide and has no regard for the lives
of the innocent people around him
now the reason I'm drawing your
attention to this is that the way Kevin
agravada picks blue Marvel here is that
he's not an antihero blurring the line
between right and wrong and instead he
is by all standards of measurement a
genuine hero and so the dichotomies
between blue Marvel and an T man come to
a head when we learn that according to
an T man humanity is a victim of his own
viciousness callousness and war
mongering while there are good
individuals out there in the mind of an
T man all humans are the same and that
if humanity won't correct the error of
its own morality then he intends to
force them to by wiping them all out now
all of this again comes to a head as the
to battle with blue mama coming out
victorious but the world also learning
that he's a black man at this point
Griffo begins to move the story away
from the basic premise of superheroes
battling one another to focusing on the
fallout of America learning that the
most powerful superhero in the world is
an african-american picking up with
Robert McNamara the real-world Secretary
of Defense under President John F
Kennedy during the 1960's alongside
President Kennedy himself and the rest
of his defense cabinet were provided the
background of blue Marvel and that his
name is Adam Brashear he graduated at
the top of his class from Cornell with a
PhD in electrical engineering and
theoretical physics with McNamara even
going so far as to state that he's not
your average colored from here the focus
switches to his power where we're told
that his actions have saved the world
on multiple occasions in one instance he
knocked a meteor the size of Arkansas
off its collision course with earth
during the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962
when the United States and Russia almost
went to war over the placement of Soviet
nuclear weapons in Cuba as part of the
u.s. naval blockade around Cuba the USS
Enterprise was damaged by a Russian
submarine at which point blue Marvel
carried the ship from the Atlantic back
to its port in the Newport News ship
escapades combined with the fact that he
had prevented the premature detonation
of the Polaris nuclear ballistics
missile to
the famous 1962 failure meant that as
far as McNamara was concerned as the
secretary of defense
Adam Brashear represents a level of
power they can't contain and that if the
fledgling civil rights movement were to
rally him to their cause the result
would be a super-powered
african-american fighting against the
government as opposed to fighting on
behalf of it and so what we do here is
begin focusing on the backstory of the
relationship between Adam Brashear and
the anti man by establishing that the
two were friends at one point and that
both served together in Korea during the
Cold War with Adam Beshear picked up by
The Secret Service at the request of the
President on his way to the White House
he flashes back to his time during the
war at some point during his tour with
the US Marines enemy soldiers ambushed
their platoon during the attack a man
named Conor was injured and adamite
intervened saving his life in the
process and running off the enemy
soldiers now transitioning back to the
war room and President Kennedy the view
of Adam Brashear comes into play when
one of the generals refers to him as a
porch monkey now the racism that Bashir
has experienced over the course of his
life is further compounded on what has
revealed that during his time in Korea
he was subjected to the taunts of other
soldiers due to the color of his skin
now this in addition is compounded on
when we learned that during the early
1960s with the United States on the cusp
of social unrest as a result of the
civil rights movement in addition to the
racism that he has experienced from
white society black society has also
demonstrated a hatred towards him due to
the fact that he will not ally himself
with the civil rights movement and
instead desires to remain a bipartisan
hero protecting the world now what
happens next is extremely important and
effectively sets the stage for
everything that comes later on as the
president who did more for minorities
than any other president in history
Griffo incorporated this into the story
by having Kennedy provide an impassioned
speech and saying the society could have
easily dealt with the racial issue
sooner by introducing desegregation
eliminating Jim Crow laws but that this
was never done because the status quo
was acceptable to white society however
when a super-powered african-american
arrived on the scene with the power to
not only force the hand of social change
but do so with humanity having no way to
stop him the attitude of white society
shifted from acceptance of the status
quo to
fear that the status quo could be
removed and there would be nothing they
could do about it and so seeing a race
war looming on the horizon due to blue
marbles continued to existence as a
superhero on earth and because the
president serves at the pleasure of the
American people Adam Brashear is called
into the White House where President
Kennedy speaks with him directly
informing Beshear that his presence as a
hero means a potential race war between
those who want to keep things as they
are and those who want change blue
Marvel is asked to step down from his
role as a superhero and so while the
question from blue Marvel is how long
this is supposed to last the indication
from President Kennedy is that after
handing Adam Brashear the Congressional
Medal of Freedom that he's being asked
to step down from his life as a
superhero
indefinitely
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I know it's a
cliffhanger but what we're going to do
is we're going to pick up with the
second half of this and we're going to
get into the current events with Tony
Stark's search of blue Marvel and how it
is he's able to bring him back and have
them become a member of the superhero
community again with that being said I
will catch you guys later peace